ferme du manet à montigny le bretonneux
la 14e édition de la fête de l'europe
bat son plein cette année le moment est
précieux pour la ville qui reçoit un
drapeau d'honneur de la part du conseil
européen
il récompense majeure pour la politique
de jumelage de montigny mais surtout
pour son action globale en faveur de la
valorisation de l'europe des 27 je vous
rappelle que nous sommes jumelés avec
eux civile le premier jumelage euros
monte à 25 ans avec l'allemagne et bien
d'aujourd'hui toute cette politique d
biannic tous les échanges qui ont lieu
qu'ils soient culturels sportifs
scolaires sont récompensés par ce prix
européen
pour bernard marquet chargé de remettre
ce prix recevra un drapeau européen
n'est pas donné à tous en france
seulement trois villes ont reçu dans
triel sur seine même si montigny le
bretonneux avait déjà été récompensé il
ya plus de 15 ans et critères sont
toujours rigoureux dans cette année y'a
qu'un bris l'europe il ya que trois
drapeaux et y a qu une dizaine de
diplômes voyez donc ce sont des
récompenses l'ipo mérité la journée
était l'occasion de rencontrer et
d'écouter les membres de l' orchestre de
la gamme schule de quers située à 80km
de cologne de quoi réviser votre
géographie et votre allemand
on est là aussi pour voir paris qui
ferait mieux connaître la france je
crois qu aucun de nous n'était déjà venu
ici
demain nous allons à paris visiter la
tour eiffel
c'est très excitant montigny organise
bientôt repenser haine qui réunit les
jeunes issus de ces villes jumelées
autour d'un spectacle vivant et la ville
espère décrocher le grand prix de
l'europe l'an prochain